and this morning Saturday sessions
rainbow kittens surprise the band was
founded five years ago in a North
Carroll Carolina college dorm
since then it's released three
full-length albums and become known for
their live performances they'll perform
in a moment but first I recently sat
down with the band Sam Melo and Charlie
Hoyt at Power Station Studios here in
New York the sound of our KS as their
fans call them is a blend of folk rock
and hip-hop you guys don't like to be
put in any particular genre do you know
I think I think we just move fast
success has come fast too the band came
together at Appalachian State College in
Boone North Carolina after Sam Melo and
Derek bazi Keller released an EP in 2013
it was just the people in the dorm
listening to it but that alone is nine
floors full of like 18 year old kids who
are just a buzz you know and so it's
just like yeah I got lit really quickly
they filled out their group with three
school mates from their dorm
Ethan good pastor Jess Haney and Charlie
Hoyt we developed a lot through the live
show like we were playing these songs in
bars with nothing except their guitars
and our voices and we're selling it
[Music]
but before one open-mike night they
realized they needed a name it's such a
nerve-racking thing because you're like
we want it to be good without think
without people thinking that we think
it's good they turn to a close friend
who just been through a tough Innes so
you asked him to name you yeah yeah it
was just like okay we got to sign up
know what's her name and no it was like
rainbow getting surprised are you
positive about that puts our fans kind
of like they're automatically defending
us from the get-go they're like hey
there's my rainbow Kings bright boy what
did you see happening I'm tore these
songs have helped me a lot personally
however the songs helped you personally
if there are lyrics and emotions that
like I've thought sometimes if some
periods of my life on a daily basis and
now I get to sing them out and it's like
almost like therapy for me
[Music]
the song hide also has great meaning
Melo wrote it when he realized he was
gay
[Music]
I wrote it like the verse chorus to that
and never sang it for anybody then I was
just like I I don't know that I'm ready
to put this out anywhere I don't know
that I'm ready to even talk to the guys
about this because it was just like a
personal sort of realization that I've
been burying
[Music]
I mean now you know I'm sitting with
Charlie and he's got fishnets on and I'm
like man that was wrong are you
surprised but where this journey has
taken you in FS no and I'll say that
because the only thing that 18 19
year-old kids can think is wow I am the
best thing to ever hit the state you're
famous we were famous for the first show
that we ever played it took us a lot of
shows to teach us that we were not and
and and when we weren't we were not as
when we finally started getting there
that's one of the best answers of that
question I've ever heard
[Laughter]